people are starting to get used to the
Breakneck pace of AI so I wanted to show
that developments in just the last few
days fly in the face of what was
predicted only a couple of years ago
starting with the upgrades The Bard then
a snapshot of Claude 2. the
all-encompassing open AI investigation
and inflection ai's predictions of a
self-guided million dollar making AI
coming in just two years but I'm going
to start with this page from a book
released in 2021 called a brief history
of AI look at the tasks it says are
nowhere near solved and at the bottom it
says at present we have no idea about
how to get computers to do the tasks at
the bottom of the list I'm not arguing
that these are solved but this year we
are getting pretty close check out the
second one down human level automated
translation I asked the new bar to write
a poem about machine translation and
here it is I'm not going to judge the
poem but then I asked now translate it
into Spanish of course that's nothing
new but listen to the quality of the
text-to-speech model used to read out
this poem here's a snippet
is
I don't know about you but that is
starting to sound awfully human-like now
yes it could do this before for English
but now it can do it for even Swahili
and I know some people will say don't we
already have Google translate but Palm 2
which is the model behind Bard
outperforms Google translate I covered
this in the original palm 2 video but
the conclusion was we observe that Palm
2 improves quality both over the
original palm and Google translate okay
that is pretty insane but what about the
next one interpreting what is going on
in a photograph are we nowhere near
solving that well I gave Bart the meme
that you can see and I said interpret
what's going on and it said this the
image shows a pizza that has been shaped
to look like the death star already that
is so Savvy to me that it knows it's a
pizza despite it being so strangely
formed and it can interpret that the
toppings make it look like the Death
Star of course as a bonus it can read
the text and therefore understand the
meme it says it's humorous because the
Death Star is a symbol of death and
destruction compared to a pizza which is
about food and enjoyment a quick bonus
tip by the way is that you can scroll to
the end of the response and click this
modify response button and then you can
adjust the output for example I'm going
to make it do something shorter and you
are going to see a shorter version of
this interpretation and here it is
apparently reduced by about 25 now the
Google lens is incorporated into Bard I
use it daily on my walks to answer
questions about things around me like
maybe I see a butterfly and I ask what
type of butterfly is or a plant and one
thing to caution you on is that if it
sees a human face it will block that out
and not answer the question and one more
crazy thing that I found that I'm
curious if anyone else found this is
that I took a photo in my local park in
air actually recognized the location of
the park and it was not a nationally let
alone internationally recognized park at
all now that didn't work every time but
it is something you might want to try on
your next walk or run and you might have
noticed that that's quite similar to the
one second from last which is
interpreting a work of art now again I'm
not saying that solved and there may be
some reverse image search going on here
I asked write a haiku about where the
stairs are going in this work of art
famously this sketch is about the stairs
going nowhere by Esha and it wrote an
almost perfect haiku about the fact that
the stairs are going nowhere let's now
take a break from that book and look at
what professional forecasters predicted
that AI would be capable of for the math
data sets for this particular Benchmark
in 2021 they put did a score of 21 in
2023 and 52 in 2025 and the predicted
Trend would hit 80 only in 2028 five
years from now seven years from then
well regular viewers of my channel might
know that gpd4 can already get 78 of
problems from that data set correct
already today and you can see here that
there is still quite a lot of room for
further Improvement and honestly this is
without code interpreter or Wolfram
Alpha so I actually ran hundreds of
experiments of my own using g64 with
code interpreter on the math data set
and it was getting more like 86 correct
but back to predictions from 2021 notice
two of the other categories that are
apparently nowhere near solved
understanding a story and answering
questions about it and writing an
interesting story here is a 112 page
novel written fully by gpt4 now I think
it meets the definition of being
interesting if not human level but
honestly when a model can be fine-tuned
on an author's work I think it will get
very very close my own prediction is
that we are less than a year away from a
human level novel not as good as the
best of course but fooling many readers
but here is where I can explore a bit
with Claude 2 which can take in a
hundred thousand tokens I was lucky to
get early access to Claude 2 and around
hundreds of my own experiments which I
will talk about more in future videos
but for this video remember the books
predictions about answering questions
about such a novel or story well I
inputted that entire gpt4 generated
novel and I said find 10 sentences whose
vocabulary could be made less generic
and if you look at these suggestions
from Claude 2 it does indeed make the
vocabulary more exciting definitely not
perfect still quite generic but we have
words like crystalline ethereal and
inaugurable I I love that word myself
one of my favorites again I think we're
less than a year from a high quality
full-length novel being produced using
one prompt and if you wanted a more
technical test of reading comprehension
don't forget that gpd4 got 99th
percentile in the verbal section of the
GRE which includes reading comprehension
I managed to get 170 on this test and to
be honest when I saw Gypsy 4 get 99th
percentile that was a huge wake-up call
for me a true story actually is that
when I saw that result I decided to make
covering AI my full-time job and I think
each person will go through their own
such moment when gbt4 or GT5 or Gemini
crosses some Benchmark to do with their
profession it's like I didn't wake up
much when it could create basic art
because I'm not an artist but when these
models come onto territory that you
yourself know about that's when you
realize how powerful they are and I
think a lot of people have gone through
that Journey this is metaculous if
that's how you pronounce it and their
predictions about AGI and look what the
predictions were two years ago around
the time of that book they were late
2030s even early 2040s and this was as
late as October or November of 2021. you
can see that they thought AGI would be
20 or more years away what do they think
now well
2026. that is quite a change in two
years and I can understand why Mustafa
Suleiman the founder of inflection AI
goes further they are building towards
their own AGI and they plan to ask it to
go make one million dollars of course it
would need a strategy it would need to
research and design products etc etc
maybe with a little bit of human
approval but the work would all be done
by an AI and he says something like this
could be as little as two years away and
those of you who watched my previous
video on super intelligence will find
that quite a contrast to the idea that
super intelligence is 10 to 20 years
away I don't know about you guys but I
think if an AI can make money in this
way the entire world economy will be
transformed rapidly there is a curious
possibility though that such an AI
wouldn't be released to the general
public of course I was following the FTC
investigation into openai as you might
expect I read all 20 pages of the
investigation multiple times in fact Sam
Altman openly grumbled that the FDC
request started with this leak enabling
me to read about it it is actually a
crazy document and it feels to me a bit
like some sort of strip search like they
want all internal Communications about
the propensity of chatgpt to produce
inaccurate statements or reveal personal
information and they say at the top do
not delete any emails relating to this
in other videos I've covered how any
model can be jailbroken and I've also
covered how Sam Altman said that it
might be two years before models stop
hallucinating so if the FTC ends up
finding open AI or the other companies
billions of dollars as they find other
companies before I can see one result
being much more reticence from these
companies over publicly deploying their
models of course let me know in the
comments whether you think that's a good
thing or a bad thing speaking of money
though I can't leave out that this week
was the start of xai Elon Musk was able
to promise up to 200 million dollars as
a signing bonus for some of the AI
researchers that joined him if companies
are willing to promise that much to
researchers willing to defect from
deepmind or open AI I do find it hard to
see the march to Super intelligence
slowing down much so let's end with that
famous scene from iRobot although
perhaps this time with a different
ending an imitation of life
can a robot write a symphony
can a robot turn a canvas into a
beautiful masterpiece
thank you so much for watching and have
a wonderful day